there's a part where you tell that i saw
you where they were talking about how
you asked the feds to let you get back
in prison for two weeks to be able to
face off with john to tell him to his
face
that you're about to flip were you in
that moment conflicted whether you were
going to tell them or whether you were
going to kill them like your decision
hadn't been used
me and frankie lecation we were in
prison
it was out there frank you agree that
was the story that's why john put a
contract on him
we met
in the hall
frankie told me he said sam
um nobody ever talked to me like this in
my life
and tears running down in his face tough
guy true tough guy
i looked at that it was sick he said i'm
gonna kill this [ __ ]
i said frankie we already killed the
ball it's gonna kill a good one
and i i was
just as mad as he was with john
at that point
and he says yeah you sure
yeah
i put my hand out as soon as we get out
we'll kill him
i was so [ __ ] up in the brain by this
betrayal
i didn't even think we could have just
killed him right down in there
sharpen up a couple of shanks the two of
us walk into the cell
our cut is strong you keep stabbing it
or you want to do it the other way
around
but instead we we were so [ __ ] up with
him
we were talking about a victory party
there was going to be no victory party
that's how we were going to kill him and
he told me she said all i want
i want to pull the trigger with it
because pulling the toss hit guys
once you've done it who cares what pulls
the trigger and i told him if that's
what you want you got it i'll have my
guys i'll bring them to a restaurant
and i'll get rid of the body
and they will claim meetings that never
showed up or whatever i said but one
more thing frankie
i'll never ever be anybody else's on the
boss again in my [ __ ] life
never
i'll be the doc the boss when we get out
and we kill him
or i'll [ __ ] die trying
said sammy i'll be your wonderboss i'll
be your captain i'll beat whatever you
want i'll be behind you with a thousand
[ __ ] percent
all i want to do is pull the trigger
with him i put my [ __ ] hand out we
shook hands and we left
that
weird mentality that we were so hurt
that's what we thought we walked away
and then we got separated we couldn't
kill no more
and then finally we had this meeting on
august uh
middle of august with that fleet valley
and he tells that fleet barely i'm not
going to do the time don't worry about
it we're going to go to a victory party
after he barely tells them no
no
this case is too strong you ain't going
nobody three party no don't worry about
it uh sammy and frank young they're
gonna take the [ __ ] weight in
athlete belly wouldn't take the case
because of that statement and he was in
an interview just recently with jerry
capisie as i said
three months was august september
october november three months later in
november he sits with me personally
we're gonna work with the lawyers
you're gonna take the weight
and i'm gonna go free
you really want that john the boss has
to be on the street
okay and i flipped
first time in my life i've pinched all
my life
from 14 years old up until [ __ ] 40
something when i went into prison
[Music]